foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Edwards football analyst back with the
mothership he's on a variety of shows
SportsCenter First Take and uh he's had
a coaching career that spanned more than
30 years now back with the mothership
where he worked there for nearly a
decade Herm the important question to
start out your favorite action movie of
all time is what
well I said uh and there's probably two
of them I'm ahead you in my bed but I
said the the uh
uh the Gladiators are one of them
obviously
that that was an action movie for me
right all right Russell Crowe yeah with
Russell Crowe I kind of like that one
um
uh Die Hard any Die Hard movie with
Bruce Willis I'm all in I'm watching you
know favorite football movie
I Remember The Titans with Denzel yeah
that's but are you watching as just a
fan are you watching with the critical
lie of having played the sport and
coached the sport look Dan kind of both
but um you know it a lot of it it just
reminds me of just Remember the Titans
obviously of growing up you know
starting football playing football
um back then it was a little bit
different than now right I mean yeah you
you know athletes are a little bit
different now compared to the era that I
played in if uh people are just
listening on radio Herm has
looks like 40 footballs behind you but
the most important football the most
valuable football that you have behind
you is which one oh
then it's hard um
I'll say this I I you know and I know
you're in La so this one right here
personal not team wise personal first
interception September 25th
1997. yep and you see what team the Rams
guess who the quarterback was Dan Joe
Namath Joe Davis
you'll love this I'm a rookie I'm a
rookie Dan we're going back to LA you
know dick coach for UCLA I'm a
California guy uh watch Joe Namath win
the Super Bowl in 68 when he's running
through the tunnel you know and now I'm
playing against him with the Rams and um
about Midway through the first quarter
he audibles and he kind of looks my way
and Harold Jackson's the wide receiver
number 29 and I'm going uh oh he getting
ready to come at me and so he throws a
goal route I intercept it and take it to
the sideline and get it taped up we're
walking after the game's over up the up
the tunnel way and there's some veterans
walking with me and I'm going you think
if I gave this ball a joke excited for
me
he said don't do that Rook don't do that
but I that's the ball that's one of them
obviously but her they do that now you
know they're asking Tom Brady to sign
his graciousness was unbelievable but
when he when I saw that on television I
said good for Tom Brady I should have
got my ball signed from Joe well Joe
will do it now oh yeah no he you know
when I first was hired at the Jets he
came by obviously and we laughed about
the story I told him the story and we
laughed about it but um I think the
second I don't know I know for the first
ball Second Ball but the championship
game we won against the Cowboys uh to go
to the Super Bowl obvious was very
important we're talking to Herm Edwards
analyst for the mothership a couple of
things to talk to you about let me start
with mahomes's injury with a high ankle
sprain yeah of what you know about that
injury what is Cincinnati's game plan or
does it change at all with Mahomes well
it's going to change somewhat I mean his
ability to create plays and extend plays
a little bit hampered but he can still
play from the pocket I mean that game
that he that he was injured Andy obvious
did a great job of keeping him in the
pocket and I think if you're Cincinnati
knowing that he can't extend your all
those boots and Waggles they like
getting on the perimeter that's not
going to be part of the deal right now
so if you're Cincinnati you gotta Rush
him from inside
you've got to bring pressure from inside
whether it's uh linebackers whether it's
a Nickelback coming inside whether it's
some stunts by the defensive line and
get him off his spot and and make him
move on the ankle now you know he's a
great baseball player
so he's unique in the fact that he can
just throw with his arm right I mean
there's a lot of plays he throws off
platform that's his baseball uh ability
right there
would you have a problem with what
happened on the sidelines if if you were
coaching the bills yeah with Alan and
Diggs what would you what role would you
play in that
well basically I would tell Diggs and
he's an emotional guy and those
receivers are all the same aren't they
the history of them I always tell them
this I know you're always open you're
like 7-Eleven get you the ball I get it
right but but I would have told him
after the game I said look man we got to
handle it this way we're we're we're in
a playoff game or even a regular season
game you know all cameras are on us our
quarterback's struggling right now your
partner rather than to stand in front of
him go sit beside him on the bench and
ask him this question how you doing
give me the ball man I can help you help
him that way don't draw attention to
yourself and then have to worry about
after the game now I gotta explain all
this you know I'm not a loser no one's a
loser this is not a losing football team
they played a tough game played a game
basically where Cincinnati was look if
you watch that game Dan I know you did
that game was over in the first quarter
and I say this they were averaging
almost six yards an attempt on first
down
you got no chance to win that game you
can't stop think about that every time
you turn around first down you're making
in six yards well you're in second and
four second and three all day they had
31st Downs you've got no chance to win
that game I knew that in the first
quarter
and we don't think of Cincinnati is a
physical team but they out physical
Buffalo in Buffalo in those conditions
they really did and for the life of me
and Coach McDermott I know he's kind of
addressed it
they got to run the ball but run it
without the quarterback Dan you you know
we're about the same age we won watching
football playing football all our life
when is the last time I can't even
recollect they've always had a running
back to Buffalo Bills O.J Simpson
Thurman Thomas oh they've always had a
great Runner you didn't mean to tell me
you can't have a running back if you
have to have a running back in Buffalo
that's part of the deal
well and then you look at the Cowboys
they got two running backs they to me
they only got one they got Pollard oh
yeah like you got to move on from Zeke
Elliott right he's in the five yard line
to give him a touchdown to keep him
happy yeah but if you look let's
troubleshoot Dallas moving forward is
Dak Prescott
a great quarterback
he's a quarterback good enough
to can he win a Super Bowl if he's
surrounded with players okay look
I say this look at the last 10 Super
Bowls the 20 quarterbacks that have
participated in that
all of them weren't Hall of Fame
quarterbacks
Joe Flacco won a Super Bowl Trent
dilford won a Super Bowl right there
have been guys that the team wins Super
Bowls when you have a quarterback
obviously he's the X Factor but most
teams me ask you this Dan there's 32
quarterbacks in the National Football
League how many of them are Hall of
Famers
there's not 32 of them and teams get to
the Super Bowl without this
is Matthew Stafford a Hall of Famer
right there maybe probably some people
would say yeah but you think about this
Jimmy Garoppolo I mean we can go on and
on but it's the Cowboys roster good
enough to win a Super Bowl no no it's
not
they need another Runner they need
another receiver
to help this guy out he's good enough
here again but in playoff competition
the Dallas Cowboys have always found a
way
to not play in the moment that's their
problem when do you they talk about the
star on the side of their helmet when
it's bright when the bright lights hit
right we see a guy in La doing it all
the time lost last night LeBron James
the Stars show up in big moments
that team has not done that is Mike
McCarthy the right coach
I think Mike's fine they won 24 games
the last two years they actually won a
playoff game this year
yeah but they beat Tampa they beat Tampa
that doesn't count I understand
did anyone think they were going to beat
San Francisco
they could have beaten them if if I if
Dak plays an average game Herm they they
can win I agree if he doesn't turn the
ball over yeah but that's a lot of
quarterbacks in playoff game hey
Josh Allen turns the ball over
we're not getting rid of Josh Allen well
well who would you rather have Josh
Allen or Dak Prescott well you want Josh
but you could win with Dak Prescott look
the 49ers are going to win with Brock
Purdy yeah I know I know
uh
biggest concern you would have for Brock
Purdy now so being a defensive minded
guy
here he is big stage he's yet to lose
um didn't look great last week now what
do you do what's the game plan for the
Eagles against Brock Purdy get to get a
two score lead make him play from a
deficit where he has to go back and
throw
yeah but you gotta get a two you gotta
you gotta get two touchdowns against
that defense but and and that has been
that has been the formula of Coach
Shanahan the kid is never under duress
because he's going to run the ball he's
going to manage the game for him he's
going to make sure he gives him some
passes that he can complete and and the
defense keeps them in the game see and
that's what's great about how they're
playing he's never been under stress to
say you know what it's the fourth
quarter I'm down two scores now you're
gonna go back and throw
we have we haven't seen that
was it protected what would you do if uh
you're running the Packers
oh boy
[Laughter]
[Music]
and Aaron Rodgers has a way look we're
in the championship game we're talking
about more than Aaron Rodgers and the
Dallas Cowboys and we're talking about
the four teams that are actually playing
the championship game how about that how
about that look I yeah
if they if they think the other guy is
the guy I
but you have to know by now I think they
know you think Jordan love is is a is
the future for Green Bay yeah and Aaron
Rodgers it's kind of sounding like if he
doesn't get his guys back he's trying to
beat a GM and the coach
right you can't you just need to play
quarterback if you want to leave just
say I'm going to leave
this is kind of the Brett Favre scenario
all over you know
if I could move on if you said we can
get two first round picks and he is
going to go someplace and we get out
from underneath all of this turn it over
to Jordan love we may take a step back
but we're probably going to take two
steps forward eventually if we and they
they draft really well
Packers very good and I I would move on
in a second no emotion attached to it
it's a business decision agree it is
business and you know when you think
about that division the lions are in it
they had the best division record they
were five and one uh the Vikings were
four and two Green Bay was three and
three so it all to me starts in the
division and three and three ain't good
enough and if you just bring those same
guys back I don't know if you get
anywhere you know you're right I would
probably go in another Direction because
you know
the the problem with Aaron is it seems
like he's year to year yeah you can't
keep living this way
as an organization if I uh if I gave you
an expansion team and I said you can
have Joe burrow Josh Allen Justin
Herbert
or or somebody else
but you can't have my home okay I'm home
no no I would take bro okay and he
reminds me a lot of Joe Montana
with this accuracy with his Poise in the
pocket and he and here's the one I
really like he has a catchable ball
a catchable ball and when you watch that
Buffalo game in those conditions
I mean he has touch
and you know and he
it's just he just he knows how to
operate he he does a great job of
processing the information getting the
ball out
um everybody talked about his offensive
line they were worried about the
offensive line I said let me tell you
something they're making six yards on
first down he ain't gonna have to worry
about holding the ball the balls coming
out did you have any success against
Montana
uh yes we we did
um and then Joe came to us when I was in
Kansas City uh if you remember with uh
that's right yes when I was on that
staff with Marty how about this staff
it's Marty Schottenheimer it's Bill
Cower it's Tony Dungy it's Bruce Arians
we were all on that staff and that's the
one and you'll remember the game you'll
remember the game
this is the this was the team we had
Derek Thomas and all those guys we get
Joe Montana and I can remember when we
getting Joe I called him Joe Legend I
told the players I said you know what
you guys are stars Joe Montana shows up
he's a celebrity there's a difference
you guys are stars he's a celebrity of
the group so we're playing we get to the
championship game we go to Buffalo
they knock him out
in the second quarter and we lose the
Buffalo Bills go to the Super Bowl you
guys had so much talent Kansas oh if you
remember that team oh boy yeah Christian
Okoye very word Yeah Boy
Nigerian Nightmare uh where is the
Miracle at The Meadowlands football
uh it sits where is it like
where is that thing oh so you do have
that oh yeah oh come on that's first
touchdown where is it at it's um oh
so Joe passarchik hands off to Larry
zonka zanka uh wasn't expecting the ball
and and Herm picked it up and took it
back Eagles won 19 to 17. right there
there it is first first NFL touchdown
you didn't ask uh Joe passarchik to uh
autograph that did you listen to this
and you're gonna love this story
so the next year Joe comes to
Philadelphia as the backup quarterback
he's going to back up Jaws
so imagine this
the locker room was downstairs we're all
in the locker room
and we're knowing he's coming down they
called the equipment guy Joe's coming
down so all the whole team gets around
the door before the door opens we're all
standing there and Jaws is standing next
to me and that's Rhonda worship for all
those guys to know what you who draws
that's Ron Jaworski and when Joe walks
in with dick
jaws has the ball
and he drops it on the ground and he
hollers out Play It Again Sam I pick up
the ball and give it to Joe
now you spike the ball when you score oh
so how'd you get it back some one of the
ball boys you know I'm not thinking
because you know I throw it down and
then at the end of the game I go
I should have kept that ball and the
ball when the ball I got the ball I said
oh that's good thanks I wasn't even
thinking
here's the crazy part there so I spiked
this ball right dig for meals on the
sideline imagine this he's got his back
turned he's with jaws and Harold Carmike
and all those guys said if we get the
ball back we're going to do this play
this Razzle down he misses the play he
doesn't even see it
the players are running off the bench
she grabs what the player
he says where are you going
coach
[Laughter]
uh
um I'm glad you're back at the
mothership always great to talk to you
Herm thank you very much anytime my
friend God bless you now all right Herm
Edwards ESPN football analyst